julian's out stripper yeah i uh started
an only fan
you can't look me around
yeah casey used that cut thank you
you can see uh feet pics
[Music]
hello everybody welcome back to big mood
not to to our own horn but we have like
a really good episode coming up for you
but before we get into it we are going
to give a shout out to our sponsor
native
my favorite part about this time of the
year is the food i just love all of the
scents of the holidays and this year i
get to also smell like the food with
native because you're a snack i am quite
a snack or as my husband says a heavy
lunch
we don't quote him okay he doesn't get
to eat anymore so native has very
limited time holiday sense and oh my god
they smell delicious so i got sugar
cookie deodorant and i got candy cane
body wash and i'd be smelling like the
holidays all the time you can stay merry
happy and fresh this holiday season and
you will love natives limited time
seasonal products as much as i do go to
nativedeodorand.com big mood girls or
use code big mood girls to get 20 off
your first purchase at checkout that's
nativedeodorant.com
big mood girls or use code big mood
girls at checkout for 20 off
nativedeodorant.com code big mood girls
and now
for our main event
guess who's on set guess who's that
becca again
we got julia in the house the one and
the only julia chap yeah it's been a
while guys have you been oh you know
honestly i've been living a really
boring life just been like
can we can we cut can can you say
something more interesting
um julia's not a stripper yeah i uh
started an only fan yeah
you can look me around
yeah casey used that cut thank you yeah
you can see uh feet pics um
oh god shoulders you can see more
shoulders now what about tailbone
dude honestly i was really thinking
about it i was like
just because i'm like yo your girl needs
more dude you would kill it
are you kidding me yeah yeah i don't
know
of all the people this one seriously i
feel like no all of you guys would be
good no no you were the no no you don't
understand you're forbidden
yeah
the foreign girl yeah oh good girl gone
there yes
if you showed like one underboob yeah
yeah just just
just cover the nails and like just that
tiny little bit of skin right there you
can paint all the mortgages
a little sailor moon outfit but with
just like the bib thing that she has
yeah
maybe i'll i'll save the reveal for a
big mood episode
oh my god yeah yeah oh my god you know
what you heard it here first
we get exclusive heard of your first
news love it um okay well
to get to know julia a little bit better
for those of you who maybe don't know
her we are bringing back the we're not
really strangers game not sponsored at
all but check them out we're not really
strangers check them out on instagram
online they have an online deck that's
for friends but they have a lot of other
decks too like a relationship they have
a lot of decks they have a lot of people
they love them
and they have workplace ones and
basically what it is is
conversation starters to get you talking
about stuff that's
a lot deeper than just the small talk i
[ __ ] hate small talk
yeah so uh this one is inner circle this
is the the deck we're using is the inner
circle
i like the inner depth yeah
and it's for people that that feel like
they know each other and we'll see how
deep we really know each other
and we've known each other we've known
julia for quite a long time
but do we know her do we really know
each other when did she come in cj what
year uh 2013
almost 10 years for me with you
holy [ __ ] for
yeah you're right
wow
i came in 2015 end of 2015. yeah you
came i came
[Laughter]
okay so how it works is there's a couple
different levels and we're just gonna
pass the phone around this one makes it
really easy because i put all of our
names in so it tells you whose turn it
is oh okay
i'll start with me because that's what
it says no one wants to hear your time i
know i make mine fast you guys better
know this answer let's find out this is
this question is what what's on the back
of your phone is that any sensitive
information
uh this is my birthday so yeah it is i'm
[ __ ] young don't try to look at it
dude those people are 18 now are you 19.
the 90s and the 80s as the late 1900s
how [ __ ] dare you did you see that
that meme that was like um i gave my
bartender my id and she took like half a
second and gave it back and i was like
that was fast and she's like yeah i saw
the 19. yeah yeah if it's 19 something
then you're older
yeah i saw a tick tock where these kids
you know like spirit week dressed up as
80s dressed up as yeah 60s they have a
dress up as 2000s now gosh like what
yeah
we're a theme now i am so offended that
our music growing up is now considered
oldies yeah yeah classic
no flashbacks okay
you guys all you [ __ ] better get this
one okay what do you think is my main
love language
what are they again they're quality time
active services acts of service gift
gift giving physical words of
affirmation yeah yeah
not that one not the gifts one
acts of service or quality acts of
service
and and acts of service and maybe words
of affirmation
[Laughter]
if it was gifts i don't know if you're
if it's gifts because you give me gifts
because knowing that's mine or is it
actually yours
no no okay you guys hit it okay well
actually i think i'm a i think i'm a
high maintenance love language person
because i tied three i've tied two and
then the third one was right high
maintenance everyone should get all of
them anyway
but my language is super high and then
the gifts and the words of affirmation
were
non-existent
but the acts of service and the quality
time were tied and the physical touch
was right underneath it i'm like that
makes sense because if any of those are
lacking i feel very unloved yeah i mean
you should get all of it ah but you can
like not give me gifts forever and yeah
never it's fine praise me and i'd be
fine yeah all right who's next
who's that we got uh oh i just think i
just tap it yeah i tap so you tap the
right hand side okay so it's julia's
turn oh okay
um what do you think i'm most sensitive
to oh sunlight
you know you are
wrong dude literally i peeled out so
much during the quarantine
i feel like i could be a bounce board
right now yeah
for sure
[Music]
you should get a refund
but um okay what are you most sensitive
to hmm
yeah i've never thought about it i feel
like i've seen you cry but i can't
remember for what yeah we were crying in
france because we were talking about our
love story oh that's right that's right
yeah yeah that was really cool yeah it
was really cute we cried in paris
together because we were sharing
personal stories it was really sweet
someone cheating on you
um that's anyone wouldn't be sensitive
to them yeah
dude i don't even know hold on let me
think about this yeah what would hurt
you the most
if your favorite pokemon died in front
of you
oh no
see see i know my girl
we've roommates we've roommated in like
three different countries
uh
sunlight is still the best answer
no literally no seriously okay check
this out all right so i went to go see
my doctor earlier this year because it
was like maybe about almost like a year
and a half or two years since i've last
seen them just for a physical right i
got my blood work done i already kind of
figured out what my results would have
been which is like like uh kind of like
high cholesterol and then being mildly
anemic those are those
high cholesterol i don't know you're
like i mean it's probably all the sugar
i drink from boba
yeah most likely
yeah so yeah so i want to go uh see the
um see the doctor get my blood work
those are the results and then i went to
the pharmacy to um pick up some
medication and then it says oh it wasn't
ready but we can get you your vitamin d
pills and i was like
vitamin d like what like the supplement
they're like yeah i'm like okay it's
like did your doctor not
send you a message i was like i don't
remember seeing a message like yeah they
ordered it like a week ago i'm like okay
yeah sure sure yeah okay uh all right
yeah let me pick that up and they're
like okay cool can you wait outside and
then i looked at the waiting room and it
wasn't like that super crowded but then
i was like okay i guess i covered
whatever right so i'm standing outside
and i'm like
vitamin d is like you can get that from
the sun
am i [ __ ] pale that i need to stand
out in the [ __ ] sun just to get some
vitamin d and then later i get text
messages like hey your vitamin d order
is ready to pick up and so i go in and
then the pharmacist was talking to me
and i was like hey so um you are
severely deficient
so that's scary because it seems like
kovid would be worse with someone yeah
it's very deficient too yeah yeah plus
um i was deficient in vitamin d and my
my doctor was freaking out because she
was like she's like you have to start
taking and taking this seriously because
it can lead to like alzheimer's and like
deterioration of your brain you can go
senile quicker
yeah crap
seriously you should you should you
definitely should because um when the
pharmacist was like okay we need you to
put on like high dosage pills for 12
weeks yeah
i'm like wait what how much and she's
like we need you to take a high dosage
pill once a week for three months and i
was like three months okay cool cool
cool cool so i pick up the package i sit
in my car like damn
he's like i can't believe i stayed
inside and just sit in the sun like in
the summer do you ever sit by the pool
or anything like that yeah because
my work hours are from 10 a.m to 7 p.m
and so by that time like the sun is
already setting like in the summer time
so i don't really get much but i didn't
realize i was severely lacking in
vitamin d because i was looking up like
what the symptoms were and it was like
hair loss skin issues and those were the
things that was happening throughout the
whole entire year and i was like what
the [ __ ] is happening why is my hair
falling out like oh my god i know it
falls out naturally but it's just like
it was such a large amount that i was
like i don't even [ __ ] know what's
going on right now do you know what else
is like i was like i did go on the sun a
lot but i still was deficient yeah my
birth control was blocking the
absorption so that's originally why i
got off birth control
yeah i didn't know that would do that oh
man
i had it well it wasn't like a proven
thing but then i was reading online that
some birth controls can block and then
after i got off i got like absorbed the
vitamin d so i'm like okay that
definitely was it because i was a
variable okay so how much sun do you
need to get a day
like every person is different depends
on your melanin and all that [ __ ] and
you have to like show a lot enough skin
you have to have like 75 percent of your
body
stick my foot out
just stick it out and then it just
absorbs from here and it goes all
through your mouth
yeah you need a little water body there
yeah yeah i know you get like 15 minutes
a day would probably be okay okay so
start wear your spf though cover your
face i mean i drive 30 minutes of work
every day in the sun does that count
hmm
no it's not enough
through a window yeah or at least just
like take supplements you can always do
that too i'm gonna sit outside naked so
what do you think you're really
sensitive about though really like
emotionally do you have something that
like
when people do this one thing it really
hurts you when how about like if friends
like leave you or people ghost you or
people who
damn yeah no that's honestly that's like
such a good question because i haven't
really thought about it i think it's
just like
when
people say one thing and then they do
the other yeah yeah because i think for
me i'm just like
oh okay i thought it's like a break of
trust yeah kind of like okay yeah sure i
guess you know and i guess i guess
really confused about it i don't know i
can't really think of one in particular
sometimes it's hard to know unless
you've like been through something kind
of traumatic and you're like well this
person did this thing and then like you
know i'm sensitive to this yeah and i
know it
i just missed her so much do you have
one for miss gina yeah
okay uh well
it only gave us us two for the first
level and then so i just went to level
two this is close friends
and uh it's gina's turn okay here do
this one with jess because it says julia
all right uh asked me something you
think is off limits
jess me yeah both players oh so i have
to ask you one huh and you have to ask
me one oh what do i think is off limits
with you you ask me something you think
is off limits like a question that you
would think is off limits for me
oh crap
i don't know i god that's that's hard
what do i think is off limits i don't
know i don't really have any
off limits or off limits boyfriend
questions oh yeah
[Laughter]
i feel like she would probably tell me
yeah
um but like on camera yeah
yeah that's way different yeah
what would be off limits asked jess
we're just like in a stare down
what would be off limits to ask miss
gina
i don't i can only call jess can you
watch my cat for a month no absolutely
not
that's not awful or just can you go i
think it's about it's not about doing
something it's about personal the only
thing i can come up with yeah the
audience is like you better give us
something good right oh my god
what's your iq i don't even know what
that i don't know
i have no idea
only nerds know that [ __ ] damn
i guess i don't know like what's your
dirtiest secret
well it's all out there yeah everything
yeah not even one that you've kept to
yourself um doubt i would tell you yeah
so is that off limits
no just what's your dad's name
you never talk about you never say his
name i don't know if you keep it private
maybe yeah yeah that's a thing i don't
know right yeah i guess so that's
awesome do you like family personal
family information yeah yeah
this is hard because if we were sitting
here privately if we weren't on camera
it would be a lot easier
so i really want to know this all right
jess
cause these are gonna take a while
anyway yeah yeah okay let's see
all right maybe we'll find something
juicy and then we'll figure it out
they're gonna be so decent if you if you
if you think of one later like that gets
sparked by it then maybe we can revisit
it so yeah like oh i have something that
might be off limits to ask so we'll come
back because there's a difference
between off limits between us and off
limits with cameras yeah
yeah so um what is a moment in our
relationship that you felt undeniably
loved
wait i'm supposed to answer yeah
jesus i can't recognize love
he does not detect
we're all crying but jesus
um
so if i answer it for you guys um jesus
i know when we were at big bear and i
was like crying because it was like my
mom's anniversary and then gina came up
to me specifically and was holding me
because she noticed my energy was weird
and she was just holding me she wasn't
asking me anything or making me talk
about it or anything but she held me so
that was one with gina yeah
um
nikki
i don't know i just [ __ ] hate you
i'm always roasting here telling you
she's ugly and stuff
i don't know she's always feeling loved
by me um yeah i don't know gosh it's so
difficult because like i don't get
i feel like for me love is kind of like
where i get uncomfortable so if
i like gina showing me that much
support and comfort it was almost so
uncomfortable that it stood out as love
to me where i was like oh this is like
repulsive because it's so
so like i don't think a lot of peop i
let a lot of people feel comfortable
enough to show me that much love
for me to even accept it yeah i think
that's kind of hard for me to answer
yeah and i don't think that i
necessarily make other people feel that
loved either
particularly or not like in such an
obvious gushy way yeah like maybe like
the fact that i'm always there proves it
but i don't know that i do think that's
kind of like how i feel too
yeah like i feel like you know any of
you could call me at any hour of the day
and i would be there
but i don't know if i've like done like
a standout act
yeah that's like i got a man
some olive
wood
uh cheese knives
for your charcuterie charcucci bars
i don't know yeah i feel loved by the
amount of uh
like
the way that you show love like so each
person's different in the way that they
show love and i feel like you're the
type that shows love by
like being there you know like in um
like you won't just like leave someone
hanging like you're dependable
you know like when we have an issue with
someone outside the group like you'll go
do whatever it takes to
to like resolve the issue or make people
feel good or if there's like an argument
or dispute you won't just like let it
hang there you know like we'll we
resolve it and i feel like those things
like all build like a deeper
relationship that it's like to me that i
feel loved
yeah i thought i felt like when i was um
co-hosting on jk news
uh with tiff and then you came in to
help on with like finding articles and
stuff like that i felt like my back was
covered when you're just like i just
want to make sure that like you guys
don't get trashed talked on and then you
started like tearing up a little bit i
was like just your dog yes just a little
bit like her voice was all shaking she
was like she's like i don't want you
guys to to get like to get like bashed
on and i was like oh [ __ ] i was like
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
cover my back yeah let's do this and i
just remember i was like
yes because i think at that time you
were still pretty new into the company
so i was like damn this girl has so much
care
there was this one particular time that
i felt very loved by you but i don't
know if i could talk about on camera so
because we had sex
so oh my god
no it was when like i wanted to die and
you showed up at my door when i didn't
even like want anybody to come over
and you were you were just there you're
like suicide watch exactly yeah yeah
i think
your strong suit when it comes to
showing love or your words whether it be
giving advice or
um comforting us like you might not be
the
hugging i love you i'll buy you
something it's more like hey
get your [ __ ] together i'm here for you
you're a tough love person yeah and like
there are so many times when i'm like
texting the group in the middle of the
night when everyone else is asleep and
you're like all right i'm gonna call you
right now like we're just gonna facetime
and you're just there to talk and you
give sound advice you're very
um
you defend your friends a lot and that's
where i find love in you
thanks guys yeah
i guess i do show some sort of love yeah
even cactuses
have some flowers sometimes
you can eat a cactus you know
tiffany's dying in the background
[Laughter]
hey it's getting a little emotional in
here but you know what makes me even
more emotional is wine
and boy did i get to try a lot of really
good ones from bright sellers like legit
they do a fantastic job dude answering
the ques you take a quiz and they don't
even ask you wine questions they ask you
like what's your favorite candy and
what's your favorite uh you know popcorn
or whatever and then they send you wines
that you're like oh my god they nailed
it yeah they absolutely nailed people
like bottles of wine yeah i still have
one that i'm like saving because i'm
like okay these wines were too good and
i'm a cheap ass and like these are
actual good ones um but anyway uh fall
is coming and if you're like me that
means cozy sweaters pumpkin spice lattes
and switching over to red wine oh i'm a
hella red wine drinker if you're a
seasonal wine drinker or just looking
for a change of pace this fall you need
to try bright cellars they make it super
easy for you to discover wines you love
talked about that they do a quiz it's
really easy they have somalias source
their wines from all over the world to
assure each box has new wines you have
not tried
awesome and then all the wines come with
education cards so you can learn about
the wines the tasting notes like what it
pairs with you know all the fancy stuff
you can impress your friends you're like
do you know that these pork chops
compared perfectly with this wine
this fruit forward pinot noir this is
wine first
this wine pairs perfectly with the salt
from your tears when you're crying oh my
god
all wine
perfect for date night wine tasting or
finding your new favorite wine for a
netflix binge speaking of red wine i had
the most amazing pinot noir from them oh
my god it was like the perfect balance
of
smooth and like not too heavy
or meaty and doesn't make you do that
pucker thing
you know and it wasn't like too bitter
it was like nice and sweet and it was
wonderful just absolutely delightful i
highly recommend and the best part is if
you don't like a bottle of wine
brightsellers offers a delayed guarantee
and will send you a replacement bottle
in your next order so you can try it and
you're like no take it back
chugged it all already yeah you sent
another one yeah i don't like it
help support us by supporting bright
sellers for a limited time big mood
listeners get 50 off their first six
bottle wine box by going to that's a lot
by going to brightsellers.com mood it's
basically six bottles of wine for the
price of three so get fifty percent off
your first box head to brightsellers.com
mood link in bio that's
h
b-r-i-g-h-t
c e l l a r s dot com backslash mood
bright cellars helping you discover a
wine you'll love you know where my
favorite place to drink wine is right
now straight out of the bottle where on
my purple mattress yeah
comfy it's just very classy drink and
pass out and not have to move at all uh
there are all these gimmicks that
promises a great night's sleep and i
don't care what kind of toppers they are
or how heavy a blanket might be it's not
that great if you're sleeping on a
terrible mattress your sleep will be
terrible it's that simple that's why i
recommend sleeping on a purple mattress
only purple mattresses have the gel flex
grid it's a super stretchy ultra squishy
material that adapts and flexes around
pressure points and doesn't retain heat
at all the gel flex grid is amazingly
supportive for your back and legs while
cushioning your shoulders neck and hips
no matter how you sleep unlike memory
foam which remembers everything the gel
flex grid purple mattresses bounce back
as you move and shift you'll never have
that unstuck feeling
that people get with their memory foam
try your purple mattress risk free with
free shipping and returns financing is
available too i recently got the the
pillow it's a very it's a very strange
little pillow it's squishy but i've been
hunting for a good like side sleeper
pillow for a long time and there's a
bunch of brands are like oh we make the
perfect size sleeper pillow and it
sucked but with purple i've actually
been sleeping really i like the way it
feels like actually like because when
you see the grid on tv you don't you're
like maybe it's kind of hard or
something yeah it's like it's actually
really it's actually really soft like
squishy it's a lot softer than it looks
and it feels really good and it stays
really cool like that pillow because i
got the same pillow too like i just like
just by moving it around i could feel
like how cold it is it feels cold and it
doesn't make your pillow flat like you
know when you're sleeping through the
night like your pillow gets flatter and
then you're not as supported it like
stays the same level of support yeah
uh getting a great night's sleep starts
with having a great mattress get a
purple mattress
right now you'll get 10 off any order of
200 or more go to purple.com big mood 10
and use promo code big mood 10. that's
purple.com bigmood10 promo code
bigmood10 for 10 off any order of 200 or
more again that's purple.com big move 10
promo code big mood 10 terms apply
yay
all right here's a fun one to break up
the emotions
uh so it says is a wild card and my
partner's julia so julia we're gonna
sing our favorite song lyrics that you
can think of off the top of your head
both of us okay whatever your favorite
song is whatever my favorite song is
okay ready okay one two three nowadays
i was listening for julian
yeah
i love that song wow i wouldn't expect
that that's awesome yeah that's a cute
song i totally forgot all the lyrics
even though it's my favorite song yeah
yeah it's been it's been a while i mean
you probably don't still listen to it
every day right yeah
they said that gen z how they see the
90s is how we saw the 60s oh god
yeah
that's my heart
shut up gina go away right
stop picking on me
talk i gotta get off your polling
okay so for these i think just read the
questions if it's addressed to you okay
okay like how jested okay yeah uh what
are you currently working through that i
don't see so what are you working
through that we don't see
that you're willing to share with the
world
i think um vitamin d deficiency
uh that um
yeah we can't see that
[Music]
tackling that down but also um
trying to like quiet down that little
voice in my head where it's just like
i was like oh i don't know if you can do
this like at this time or i don't know
if you can do this right now it's like
do you do you even have the ability to
do things like that
yeah yeah so it's just like there are
things that i i would like to do but i
think the person inside my head is like
oh i don't know about that and then
typically when that happens i'm like
okay just like your personal life or
your work life yeah so it's like um
it's like
so i'm like a production coordinator for
an animation company right now and i've
only thought about
staying as a coordinator for a while and
then people are like you should become a
manager like a manager would be the next
step and i'm like yeah but i don't know
if i'm like ready to be a manager so
it's like kind of talking myself down
already without having to see the
potential of me becoming a manager would
you like to be a manager or is it just
because it's the next step like or is
that something you want to do or is it
something that you just don't think you
can do
i feel like it's something i think i
can't do
but you want to yeah
then like i think for me i'm just like i
don't know that's a very sad
feminine trait that i think a lot of us
have i mean in the workforce it's a it's
a very very common thing for women to
undervalue their actual abilities and to
be like oh if i can't do it at a hundred
and ten percent then i'm not qualified
yeah but you know a lot of people
actually do things before they're
qualified and then they figure it out
and that's how you move to the next step
so that's yeah right now too it's common
to think that just thrown in there but
it's wrong you're not you're you're yeah
yeah i know so i'm working on like
manifesting that yeah a lot more and
just telling myself like yeah that is
your goal you should hit that goal like
you should try and learn like things
that can make you become a manager and
then that way you know you're never
you're never going to be prepared until
you're there yeah exactly so working on
that
i mean you've been through a lot of
shitty crazy stuff with us i think
you're prepared for a little yeah
like when i'm working because like i i
just it's pretty much i'm working from
home and i'm working off of my laptop
and i'm just sitting in front of it and
i totally forget that i had a youtube
career yeah like there are days where i
completely forget about it but then i
know that all of you guys are my friends
yeah and like all of you guys are like
are on youtube and i'm like
wow i lived that life yeah like i
completely forget and i'm like wow
it just blows my mind and when people
are like yeah i have like youtube
questions to ask you and i'm like sure
i'll try to answer whatever i can and it
just reminds me of like oh yeah i was on
youtube
do you miss a camera at all
um i don't know i mean i feel like
it feels so second nature right yeah
that like if it is on or if it's not on
it's just it's normal
yeah yeah but i mean i don't i don't
know if i missed the camera per se i
just missed seeing my friends yeah
yeah that working from home thing kind
of kind of sucks after a while i feel
like i don't know i think you're one of
the people that's like your life quieted
down a lot a lot a lot yeah yeah you
know like because we're still in front
of the camera running around and you
like you really just now like a quieter
more behind-the-scenes stuff yeah
whenever i see a julia picture pop-up
i'm like oh my god yeah yeah
yeah i seriously haven't posted a month
because i just felt like there was
nothing it's a different day
yeah it's hard it's crazy i've been
posted on my instagram in like a year
oh really yeah wow my oldest or yeah
well i did stories i did archive my uh
car photo but before that it was just
when we were at that
that house at airbnb doing all those
photos that was over a year ago i was
wearing like the green pants yeah black
shirt yeah like i haven't posted
anything i do stories i guess yeah yeah
there's nothing
instagram's boring anyway all right
gina cochina yeah
here you go
okay oh weird okay
how can i add how can i add one percent
more happiness to your life just show up
more oh
oh yeah around that was blunt
yeah like if we invite you like just
come i'm a very remote friend
zoom in
like when she shows up we're like oh
gina came yeah
it's even worse now yeah like because
you have too many responsibilities to
also be like a friend
yeah yeah yeah how about you but you
were closer respond to my texts oh
[Applause]
yeah
but it's like it was like a yeah yeah
but i didn't get a confirmation
i did not yeah you didn't text me
diverted
same i missed you too let's grab a meal
sometime and then we left her out
for a lunch
well there was a time where she didn't
eat so
i'm a very i'm a very like i like to
call myself like a low maintenance
friend like i don't need to see you and
you don't need to see me i mean you
probably like you guys are different
yeah we're like cats yeah we're like
yeah yeah like i want to come cuddle
like when i want to cuddle yeah but like
other than that mm-hmm
but just know i love you yeah just know
that i love you just leave it yeah
i mean that's what i learned like if you
don't respond like that's genome yeah
i'm way more high maintenance than that
because like if i don't see you then you
don't [ __ ] love me [ __ ] you
because like i said my best friend from
high school i was like in her wedding
and everything she lives two miles away
from me and at one point i saw her like
once a year yeah yeah
yeah i think one of them is for your
birthday right yeah yeah that's what
happened to me my best friend from my
school that you remind me of that i
always tell you you remind me you're
just like her she moved to la and i see
her less than i've ever seen her yeah
isn't that weird yeah i think it's just
it's one of those like if uh something
goes wrong i'm there yeah you know like
i'll i'll be right there but i'm just i
spend a lot of my time just exhausted
and passed out so if you guys want to
hang out just come and wake me up yeah
come nap with you
go all right
this is for jeez
i have to answer this you say jess yeah
it says what's the hardest truth you had
to face
this past year oh
you got a different hardest truth
i don't know what's hard
um
dang that's crazy
that maybe
the idea that i had of love doesn't
exist
so
that i don't know i guess because i grew
up you know as a kind of an abandoned
child i placed all of my
ideas of life off of media right and so
even still at 35 i'm having to unravel
like i'll watch a show and i'm like oh i
want that guy to be my husband but that
guy doesn't exist because that guy's
just a story that's written by a writer
and it just doesn't kind of doesn't seem
real you know what i mean like that all
the idealistic
versions of people i feel like and the
world doesn't exist anymore like the
world as it actually is is just not
really what i thought it would be when
we got older you know
there's like
certain qualities that you find
important that you just
name as like non-negotiables but then
the rest like yeah there's no perfect
person yeah
i think that just like i think the idea
of love of someone that can support you
that like and not just not financially
but just like it supports you as a
person
and like gets you i think like
understands you to be understood i feel
like is
is that
that kind of love and and to have
someone that's has their same life
values and you guys just have like a
good time together
yeah i think that does exist but
when i just look at people and like how
they are how the dating scene is like
how just how people just are i'm like i
don't like any of them you know like
just in general i'm just like i just
don't like anybody
it's weird and i'm like i didn't think
that that's how it was gonna be
but maybe you know i'll change my mind
later yeah every position in life is
temporary but yeah i wouldn't
necessarily call it like a hard truth
yeah but maybe just some
adjustments you're making right now to
like be okay with
the outcome like yeah maybe you were
really attached to an outcome a specific
outcome and now you're learning to be
more open now i have like zero outcomes
yeah yeah there's nothing now like
nothing is probably what i wanted but
maybe something else will be there later
i don't know something that might
surprise you yeah with like that you
didn't even expect that you like better
yeah yeah maybe you were too attached
before and like it wasn't it was
blocking the better thing that's coming
yeah how bad is that because that's that
bad yeah okay it's driving me crazy for
sure we could pause
all right we're back and so sorry if
you've been hearing hammering in the
background we just took a quick break
because uh the neighbors next door are
hammering
they're hammered they're so hammered
they're just hammering for some reason
on saturday
they're not and that's not code for sex
like they're literally that's a hammer
there's a camera so that's just hammered
something without it
um anyway so it's my turn uh so who in
your life do you feel you can be most
vulnerable with explain i mean we feel
like that's so easy maybe someone else
who's the second most yeah yeah yeah
okay so steve for those of you who
didn't yeah
that's obviously um second most i mean
maybe does it
no it doesn't have to be it doesn't have
to be someone here because yeah i mean
you're someone in your life
yeah i mean my mom should i tell her
everything
she's always been there i think she
knows more about me than anyone except
for steve yeah so he probably knows the
most about me and then she's second
that's great because like i don't
neither of my parents would have been my
first or second choice so that's special
that you have that i think yeah yeah
yeah she's always been like a great
therapist when i didn't have a therapist
yeah that's what parents are supposed to
be there for oh no no no
no
no
yeah that's true
yeah yeah
all right yeah easy easy peasy here you
go i saw a quote once i said for all you
parents out there i hope when your kids
grow up they still think you're as cool
as they thought they were where you were
yeah when they were good yeah
okay so it says my partner for this one
is you nikki oh
so it says wild card set an intention
for this next week stick to it both of
us yeah i guess so our own intentions or
our group
i guess it could be anything really they
just said set an intention for the next
week do i have to tell you yeah
this is kind of like people are watching
us play this game so yeah we gotta it's
kind of a secret
secret oh
be better at butt stuff
[Laughter]
why would you serve the patriarchy in
that manner
no thank you it's a it's a sympathy
dilation for tiffany
an intention yeah
does that mean like anything like
anything you intend to do in the next
week i would maybe help to
try to relax my brain
okay
yeah
we're still doing this yeah
okay
you got it okay okay oh you thought
i'd have a really hard time relaxing and
we're supposed to go to like this
retreat this like big mood retreat thing
and we've been planning it forever but
it's like
the craziest week right now and i'm like
i don't know how i'm gonna be able to
relax so i'm just i'm gonna try to
be only for two presents i'm gonna try
to be present yeah yes to be mindful is
that what that's yeah be mindful
mindfulness what about you julia yeah uh
i think i'm gonna
try to wake up
at either 8 30 or 9. how would you do
that what are you you have a normal jump
though right when i do when you wake up
like right at five minutes before yeah
yeah i [ __ ] love my sleep yeah i'm
gonna i'm gonna try to wake up a little
earlier because i do feel like i should
set a morning routine for myself so
what's your morning routine going to be
um drink some water okay um
take your vitamin d yes
uh take the dogs out to go pee
and then maybe like clean a little bit
okay yeah i like that
yeah i think i kind of want to start
that but meditate
i have never
she'll probably just fall asleep i
imagine if you try to meditate you would
just pass yeah no literally like i think
any of the times i try to meditate i'm
just like
especially like waking up
earlier than normal
yeah yeah yeah so i'm gonna try to do
that okay i'll hold you to it we'll text
each other in a week okay
and i'll respond unlike some people here
thank you thank you i really appreciate
that i just need a conference well maybe
one thing you could clean uh is your
laundry perhaps maybe your sheets
our sponsor this week is attitude
the dirty little not so secret about the
bedding aisle is that while cotton might
be the most popular fabric for sheets
duvets and pillowcases it's also the
most damaging to our planet that's why
i'm so thrilled to introduce you to
etitude which offers sustainably made
bedding sleepwear bath wear and
accessories made all from 100 organic
bamboo fabric i absolutely love
these are these are probably the best
sheets i've ever
hands down i've never felt like because
i had really sensitive skin so i've
never really felt something that was
just so soft that also because my skin's
very dry and it gets irritated easily so
like even cotton or like even those
t-shirt feeling type of jersey jersey
yeah yeah they upset my skin as well
this bamboo fabric i don't know what how
they do it but it's like yourself
yeah it's so soft and it doesn't bother
my skin and even the pillow
covers i feel like they don't mess up my
hair they don't they don't you know
because like pillowcases can damage your
hair too so a lot of people who are silk
but i don't even feel like i need soap
like this bamboo is as soft as silk i
love it
anti cotton unlike cotton which consumes
massive amounts of water energy and
chemicals during production attitude
uses organic bamboo which is the most
resource efficient plant on our planet
etitude's 100 organic bamboo fabric has
a unique silky smooth and feathery soft
texture that is similar to silk it
delivers unparalleled comfort that
actually feels better than cotton at 100
percent their passion is to provide the
best quality sleep in the most
sustainable way attitudes organic bamboo
fabrics are temperature regulating
hypoallergenic antibacterial and toxin
free try attitude betting for 30 nights
if you're not completely satisfied
return it for a full refund
i love the option of a full refund
there's no risk to try you will not be
returning these things no you won't you
won't you cannot go back or i want so
many more we want more right now you can
get 20 off your order plus free shipping
when you visit attitude.com
mood and enter promo code mood remember
that's attitude as in eco attitude order
today for free shipping and 20 off your
order at etitude.com mood and use the
promo code mood and before you go to bed
in your awesome bed sheets you should
always brush your teeth with brush yes i
like the toothbrush
all black and it's so cool it's really
cool it's really cool it's the electric
toothbrush um going to the dentist can
be really nerve-wracking so you should
definitely take care of your teeth it's
super convenient because they have a
subscription program where they send you
new brush heads so you don't have to go
out and buy different toothbrushes yeah
because some people don't change out
their toothbrush and that's really gross
people's toothbrushes just like spit it
out yeah what are you doing yeah men yep
man i've only seen you steve got mad
that was one of the first fights we ever
had because i threw away his toothbrush
i was gonna replace it with a new one
and he got so [ __ ] mad at me it's
like flat yes
this is helpful that will help you know
when it's time to change your toothbrush
yeah uh there's also six unique modes to
customize your brushing experience
there's a four week battery life a
magnetic charging stand and a compact
travel case you never have to forget to
change your brush head ever again
because bruce ships you a new
replacement head every six months that's
weird only brush like once a week so why
don't
i
[Laughter]
so you're never stuck using a worn down
toothbrush head uh it's also very very
sleek brush's electric toothbrush has a
modern aesthetically pleasing design
comes in seasonal colors and looks great
on your bathroom counter
mine the one that i have is all black
and that's yeah that one looks really
great i have a golf toothbrush yeah
get 15
off your brush toothbrush kit and refill
plan when you use the code mood at
bruce.com that's 15 off using code mood
at
brush.com that's to use once again go to
bruce.com and use code mood for fifteen
dollars off your brush toothbrush kit
and refill plan two use two means it's
like a
tongue twister yeah that was julia's
turn okay gina on you
uh when was the last time you felt most
yourself
um
hmm
do you ever notice you never know you're
not yeah
i don't know like you've been pretty
consistently this yeah
pretty consistent right yeah
i guess when i'm alone at home
on my bed with no pants on and just
gross with my cat and
yeah that's something you're just gross
plucking my nipple hairs in the mirror
yeah that's that's about it yeah i've
been pretty consistently myself yeah
like it's not really yeah
all right boring
boring
all right how about you jess
okay um have i ever challenged your
world view and how so
on oh i guess you're asking us that then
yeah it seems like yeah
um
i think aliens are real and you don't
have i changed
okay so have i challenged yeah yeah okay
so i've challenged your world view that
and like yeah you think we're the only
[ __ ] people in this entire universe
i've never said that what i said
i don't think that they're here just
crawling around all over our
crawling they're aliens they're more
highly intelligent than that yeah aren't
they like reptilian or something i don't
think that they're probably morphing
around all over the place on our planet
i think aliens exist just based on
statistics okay but then i was like i
don't think you think that have they
ever visited no and she's like no maybe
ancient aliens i'm open to that never
not right now i don't think they're here
right now no sorry well i didn't stay
here right now so they ever and she's
like no no i said ancient aliens was
feasible for me we're fighting
we're gonna fight now we're doing a
fight now what about you challenging
everyone is your world view not really
because
i don't know if i've ever challenged you
on anything julia
we didn't get a lot of a whole lot of
face time no we didn't
i mean if i had to pick one thing from i
think what could kind of apply was to
not be a hoarder to navi a hoarder yeah
yeah yeah i talk [ __ ] about your horn no
no no you never talk [ __ ] directly but i
i do like i guess like when when it was
like time to like clean up stuff at the
office or whatever you're like we don't
need that and i'm like but i think we do
yeah right
eventually we'll use this i'm like no
throw it away we don't need it
and like i think that's something that i
can appreciate because i feel like i've
learned hoarding from the best of the
best which is my parents yeah um they
hoard in different ways and i think i've
got both so i'm just like the ultimate
hoarder yeah in my own world
yeah yeah
you win at life when it comes to
hoarding so
so yeah so i think um
jess i think you put into perspective
for me that like i should
learn to let go of a lot of things that
like are just gonna end up sitting there
for a long time and if i need it then
i'll just get it again yeah i feel like
a lot of times people don't actually
ever need half the crap that they hold
on to yeah that's very true yeah i
definitely want to do that but um when i
donate stuff i somehow see it recycled
back within the house and i'm like what
the [ __ ] why is this here my mom was
like oh yeah i thought i could use it
for something oh my gosh she's saying
something you're trying to get rid of
that is next level
that it cycles back into your house
literally and i think one time i was
like just trying to donate this shirt
and it was like tommy hilfiger but it
was like so old and it was like too
small for me and my mom was like
you're you're donating this like such a
beautiful shirt and i was like
uh and like the way that it translates i
guess like in chinese right it sounds
like it's beautiful but she means like
this valuable shirt because name brand
yeah and i was like yeah it doesn't fit
me she's like then i'll take it
okay
either they wear it or they can use it
as a rag or something yeah
so to me i'm like i got it yeah i gotta
learn how to do it and i have i've
thrown out a lot of stuff and i've
donated a lot of clothes i learned that
i have to donate it myself directly to
where i needed to be so it doesn't get
recycled yes yeah that's what i did too
i recently um my housekeepers are really
cute they're like hey do you have any
clothes that we can just
whatever and we can donate to puerto
rico i'm like yeah and i went through my
whole house and just got rid of a bunch
of stuff and then i realized i still
have way too much stuff yeah yeah
and you still wear your own stuff i
recycle my clothes to my friends
for the episode of the episodes yeah
yeah everyone's in it
yeah
yeah cause i was getting ready upstairs
and then i just see
uh gina go in first and she was like oh
this is really cute and i was like oh
are you wearing nikki's clothes she's
like
it's like other like if i don't like i'm
just gonna be wearing black all the time
oh okay and then as soon as gina left
jess walked in and then i was like i was
like why are you still nicki's clothes i
don't have to bring like clothes like i
used to bring wardrobe changes yeah
awesome
so i just bring a backpack now and i'm
like i'm just gonna wear nikki stuff
because the comments just keep roasting
me about wearing the same like five
shirts all the time like i don't like
shopping i don't care
at least we all wear the same size yeah
that's well until it gets too baby yeah
too much baby
it's just so selfish yeah yeah yeah we
could have been one of us no
so this is a great setup yeah she is in
my shirt right now yeah
you still fit a little yeah all right
what has brought you the most unexpected
joy recently
unexpected all my joy is expected
[Laughter]
wait when is joy ever expected
usually joy is because of like i feel
like i created my joy i'm like this is
boring i'm gonna get i'm gonna get a
house
okay what else can i do
that joy is usually typically unexpected
because like the spark of joy is usually
like it's not something you planned but
it's like that
that kind of like um
i don't know that spice of life where
like you find joy and things that maybe
you didn't expect to happen so i feel
like all joys usually i mean no i mean
you can plan you kind of know what
things do bring you joy though and then
like maybe sometimes yeah maybe
tips pointing at her pregnant belly
you think that's going to be a joyful
activity having a baby
you think that was unexpected
i'm getting to know jess's life that
she's like there's no joy unless it
surprisingly comes up
like if i plan to enjoy something it
usually disappoints me
joyce is always unexpected and
surprising when the standards are low
i feel like i just am constantly guided
by like oh no joy here oh this one yes
yeah and then i just like eat it up and
then i'm like where's more
i'm like a freaking ghost in the pac-man
game
[Laughter]
i think that joy can happen both ways
where you can plan it or just
unexpectedly happen yeah yeah yes yeah
exactly it should happen both ways yeah
because like obviously you're gonna get
some surprises so that's kind of cool
but like you have to take the action
towards like
oh this is feeling good you know and
then it like oh this came out of nowhere
cool because i was like following that
direction
or you could hit a stumbling block but
yeah
um so recently unexpected joy so i had a
lot of joy but all of it was like kind
of expected
i found that uh found a house that i
really like but i don't want to i just i
don't know if we're gonna get it but
right yeah it's joyful it's joyful
and then i released like
new jewelry pieces that i was really
excited about because i've been
designing them for a long time and
they've been just like living in my head
and now they're like getting released in
the world but i kind of like was hoping
for that feeling and then it did happen
um yeah i don't know
i came in to stay with you for the
weekend like that was expected
you're [ __ ] going back on your own
statement
and it it disappointed you know yeah
like every time i try to tell my joy i
don't blame you
i understand
i have a lot of joy
i'm very blessed
maybe it's coming still yeah yeah
here you go
okay so finish the sentence when i'm
hurt i blink
and it's with oh it says both players oh
why do you keep getting joint ones i
don't know but it doesn't tell me this
time it doesn't do with gina because you
you and nikki have done the group once
yeah with gina okay
uh when i'm hurt i blink okay
uh when i'm hurt i shut people out
mm-hmm yeah so i have um
anxious attachment uh-huh so that means
if something hurts me i'm like all right
i'm cutting enough because i don't need
to deal with this right now and that's
avoidant oh sorry
oh yeah okay never mind i i have anxious
but i guess that's not a part of it but
um
what's the second half it just says when
i'm hurt i blink when i'm hurt i shut
people out like i kind of disappear for
a little bit i cut people out and i
don't talk to anyone
and i just sit at home play games and i
don't see the sun see like a cat yeah so
that's a whole thing are you always hurt
then because you're awesome
it's worse when i'm hurt really bad um
it used to be when i'm hurt
i will say something to hurt you back
but i learned like a long time ago that
my friend my friend told me when i was
like 23 years i was like dude when you
lash out it's really it's mean
you know so i stopped doing that but for
me now it's just i just cut you off damn
that's probably healthier
it's not creating more damage yeah yeah
when you're hurt what do you do julia uh
i just get sad i get sad and then i get
quiet and then
um
if i'm quiet for a long time and then i
think about like what hurt me then i
start crying
yeah
yeah like that's how i kind of like
process it but then like i think i
wouldn't be able to talk to whoever hurt
me just like for a while yeah it doesn't
have to be like a long time it really
depends you have to process it first
yeah
because i feel like if i were to try to
process my emotions live yeah it's i
think a lot of it gets just
miscommunicated and misunderstood and
then people are like what do you mean by
that and we're just like i don't know
what i mean yeah it's like i'm just
saying this and it's like but you should
already know like that i'm not trying to
do that i was like i know
but i don't know emotions aren't logical
you have to like find the thing but it's
funny because someone like me i can
argue my emotions immediately as soon as
i feel it i already have like a 10-page
powerpoint presentation why you're wrong
you know what i mean
i want kind of that balance because it's
just like sometimes for the people that
i do face where they're like i want to
talk about it now i'm like [ __ ] like how
can i put words together to let them
know that like i can't fully do it you
have to communicate yeah like you need a
little bit of time yeah and like when i
tell them they're like no let's just do
it now i'm like oh come on no that's me
yeah that's helpful to hear that because
sometimes i don't understand like when
people can't
you know like already understand the
situation and already like discuss it
with me
probably that person i'm like you can't
[ __ ] figure this [ __ ] out right now
yeah like what's your problem like are
you hiding something or i'm like what's
wrong with you
you're lying about it yeah people need
to step away yeah i i know that when i
get very angry i have to step away
before
i say things wrong or you know yeah
that's if you want to protect the
relationship for sure and i will do that
too like i won't immediately say
everything i'm thinking if i really want
to protect your relationship too but
sometimes if i'm like if i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm just gonna [ __ ] say it
immediately
yeah yeah yeah like demand i feel like
if i'm too emotional i can't articulate
my emotions yet like i can't tell you
i'm like you like like if i'm too
emotional it's like my
my heart my heart is in my throat yeah
yeah and then i'm trying to say things
but like i'm so emotional that like it's
all coming out jumbled and i just would
rather be composed to like work through
it with the person yeah okay here's why
and this is why i felt this way a little
bit yep exactly mm-hmm otherwise it can
make it
attack first very logically and then
i'll feel it later
yeah
i feel like that's perfect in a work
setting yeah because i wouldn't want to
cry at work yeah
which is which sucks i hate that like my
emotions are just right here like all
the time like right [ __ ] here yeah um
but yeah
i think and ultimately it's it's
healthier to let them out than to
suppress it oh yeah yeah no definitely
and i just feel like in a work setting
if you do stay quiet it's just kind of
like you're accepting what they're
saying yeah you get run over yeah and
i'm just like i don't i don't want that
i want to be able to present my argument
like while still sounding like i'm not
emotional either yeah because then you
get put in this category of like oh
you're too emotional you're not you're
not making any sense like you're not
logical it's invalidated
yeah like when they when they do walk
over and you can't instantly like
like stop it or whatever then like you
become the person that gets walked over
and then later on you're like but but
you know this you know and then there's
just it's not strong enough yeah and
then you know it sucks i was valid
yeah
all right wow we are at the end of our
hour
um but thank you so much julie for
joining us let us know in the comments
if you want us to keep playing more of
these games is i feel like i'm learning
new things about everybody each time we
play i mean this is only the second time
but um it's been really really fun like
getting to know you on a deeper level
also check out julia wherever she is
she's on instagram blue is it still blue
apples yeah it's blue apples blue apples
i'll put it in the description yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then anything else going
on that you want to let people know
about
clothing she's like no i'm not
influencer
i want to be active on my youtube but i
always say that yeah you never do what
about the animation show that you work
on
um
oh yeah there's a few i worked on some
area 21 music videos go check that out
it's on youtube
um and the netflix show q force yay i
know that got a lot of controversy but
you know just watch it give it a try
give it what is it
yeah
standing for queer foreign
so stay tuned because she will be coming
back in a future episode and also check
out our sponsors let them know that we
sent you it really helps uh the show out
a lot and uh like comment do all that
stuff
get rate us on itunes
all that good stuff you already know and
we will see you next time love you bye